This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. On May 3rd, 1978, construction workers in San Francisco were digging a foundation for a new building on San St. Street. Right next to the tallest skyscraper in the city, the Trans-America pyramid in the heart of the financial district. They were about 20 feet below street level when their shovels hit something totally unexpected. It was the hull of an old ship. That's reporter Emmett Fitzgerald. Archaeologists immediately came in and started scraping away all the dirt and mud.
这里是“99%隐形”播客。我是罗曼·马尔斯。1978年5月3日，旧金山的建筑工人在三街（San St. Street）为一个新建筑挖地基。这个地点就在旧金山最高摩天大楼——金融区中心的泛美金字塔大厦旁边。当时他们挖到低于街面约20英尺的地方，铲子突然碰到了完全意料之外的东西。那是一艘旧船的船体。说话的是记者埃米特·菲茨杰拉德。考古学家们立即赶到现场，开始清理上面的泥土。
And after a few days, they'd uncovered the full skeleton of a 120-foot gold rush air of vessel called the Niantic. Preserve perfectly in the earth beneath the streets of San Francisco. of a 120-foot gold rush era vessel called the Niantic. Preserve perfectly in the Earth beneath the streets of San Francisco. As the archaeologists did their work, hundreds of people gathered to watch the bizarre scene. A massive, massive ship being pulled out from beneath the pavement. As the construction hoarding was put up, people were carving holes in it to look in and see N an gigantic emerge from the mud.
几天后，他们发掘出了一艘120英尺长的淘金热时期的船只的全貌，它名叫“尼亚加拉号”。它被完美地保存旧金山街道地表下方的泥土中。随着考古学者的工作展开，数百人聚集在一起观看这奇异的景象：一艘巨大无比的船从路面下被拖出来。随着施工围挡的搭建，人们在上面凿洞往里看，想看看“尼亚加拉号”是如何从泥潭中现身的。
That's James Delgado. I'm an archaeologist and a historian and I'm the author of Gold Rush Port, the Maritime Archaeology of San Francisco. Delgado was 20 years old then, an archaeologist in training, and he was part of the excavation that day. Inside the ship, he found all kinds of artifacts from the gold rush that had been preserved underground. Bricks, nails, tin plates for sheathing, boots, jackets, saddles, shovels, a lot of booze, 49ers like to drink. Delgado even popped the cork on a
那是詹姆斯·德尔加多。我是考古学家兼历史学家，也是《淘金热港口：旧金山海洋考古学》一书的作者。当时的德尔加多只有20岁，是一名见习考古学家，他参与了当天的发掘工作。在船舱内部，他发现了各种地下保存下来的淘金热时期的文物。有砖块、钉子、用于船身包覆的锡板、靴子、夹克、马鞍、铁锹、还有大量的酒——49人淘金者们很爱喝酒。德尔加多甚至还撬开了一瓶
bottle of 150 year old champagne. Tasted awful. But the excavation of the Niantic launched his career in marine archeology and inspired him to study the ships beneath San Francisco, because the Niantic isn't the only one down there. I'd say that there are probably as many as 70 ships that were buried that in some way
150年前的香槟酒瓶的软木塞。味道糟透了。但“尼亚加拉号”的发掘开启了他的海洋考古生涯，并激励他去研究旧金山地下的船只，因为“尼亚加拉号”并不是那下面唯一的船。我说过，那下面可能有多达70艘船被埋藏，它们以某种
shape-reform remained even if it's fragments. In 1994, city workers were digging a tunnel for the munitrain when they hit the side of another gold rush ship, the Rome, and the decision was made to drill through it. They tunneled right through the hall, and today thousands of San Francisco's travel through the ship every morning as they'd ride the train between Folsom Street and the Embarcadero. It's not really marked in the tunnel, but for those of us who know when you take that turn, you're passing through the Gold Rush Ship Room. To understand how all of these ships ended up buried underground beneath the city, we
形式和形态残留着，哪怕只剩下残片。1994年，城市工人在为城市轨道交通挖隧道时，撞到了另一艘淘金热时期的船只——“罗马号”的船舷，当时决定直接钻过去。他们直接在船体上凿出了隧道。今天，数千名旧金山人在福尔松街和恩巴卡德罗之间乘车时，每天早晨都会穿过这艘船。隧道里虽然没有明显的标记，但对于我们这些知情的人来说，当你转过那个弯时，你其实正穿过淘金热时期的船只——“罗马号”。为了理解所有这些船是如何最终被埋在城市地表之下的，我们需要
need to go back to the 1830s. When San Francisco was just a tiny little port, called Yerba Boena. It was an outpost of a few buildings with a tiny town square that set. By 1847 the population had grown to a few hundred. They renamed the port San Francisco, but it was still just a small town. But in 1848, all of that changed with the discovery of gold in January. The gold rush brought a tidal wave of prospectors to California. And by the end of 1850, the San Francisco waterfront was clogged with more than a thousand ships and the town had grown into a city of
回到19世纪30年代。当时的旧金山还只是一个小得不能再小、名叫耶尔巴布埃纳的港口。它是一个只有几栋建筑物和一个小小城镇广场的前哨站。到了1847年，人口增长到了几百人。他们将港口改名为旧金山，但它依然只是个小镇。但在1848年，随着1月份黄金的发现，这一切都改变了。淘金热给加利福尼亚带来了一波又一波的淘金者。到1850年底，旧金山的海岸线上挤满了1000多艘船，小镇也发展成了一座拥有
thousands. So you're looking at a city that within a decade has gone from being a village to being the 12th largest city in North America. But the land around San Francisco was mostly sandy hills and not well suited to the scale of development. So to meet the surging demand for real estate, the city sold off plots of water in the shallow tidal zone. A person could buy a piece of water, but it was their job to turn it into usable ground. Some people dumped sand or garbage into their plots to try and make land.
数千人口的城市。所以，你看到的是一座在十年内从一个小村庄变成了北美第十二大城市的城市。但是旧金山周围的土地大多是沙丘，并不适合大规模开发。因此，为了满足对房地产飙升的需求，这座城市拍卖了浅水潮汐区的水域地块。一个人可以买下一片水域，但把这片水域变成可用土地是他们自己的事。有些人往自己的地块里倾倒沙子或垃圾，试图造出陆地。
Others drove steaks into the mud and built platforms on top of the water. And a lot of people repurposed the ships that had brought them to California. The ships helped, because as they came, many of them were sitting idle. The crews have gone off to the diggings or had run away. So the owners rented them out or sold them outright to become floating houses, square houses, the town jail, offices. You name it. Over 200 of them became floating buildings.
还有些人在泥地里打桩，在水面上搭建平台。许多人还重新利用了带他们来到加利福尼亚的船只。这些船帮了大忙，因为当它们到达时，许多都处于闲置状态。船员们已经去淘金了或者逃跑了。因此，船主们把它们租出去或直接卖掉，用来做水上住宅、简易房、镇上的监狱、办公室，应有尽有。其中有200多艘变成了水上建筑。
Ships were the centers of commercial life in San Francisco. Well, you had the Apollo saloon, which was basically a restaurant. They sold the donut and a cup of coffee for two bits, they said. You had the euphemia, which was turned into the town jail, and later became an insane asylum.
船只曾是旧金山商业生活的中心。比如阿波罗沙龙，它基本上是一家餐馆。据说他们卖一个甜甜圈加一杯咖啡只要两毛五。还有“尤菲米娅号”，它被改成了镇上的监狱，后来又变成了一家疯人院。
You also had ships that served as water sisters. You had other ships that worked as government offices. And another ship, the good ship Panama, was used as a Siemens church. The city looked like a forest of masts, and planks connected the ships, creating a grid of boardwalks perched above the water. One visitor said that San Francisco was a Venice built of pine. But there were obvious downsides to a floating city, and little by little, people began to fill in areas between the ships using whatever they could get their hands on.
还有一些船被用作水库船。还有其他船作为政府办公地点。另一艘船“优秀的巴拿马号”则被用作海员教堂。这座城市看起来就像一片由桅杆组成的森林，木板将船只连接起来，在水面上方交织成一个木板路网。一位游客曾说，旧金山是一座用松木建造的威尼斯。但水上城市也有明显的弊端，人们开始一点一点地用手头能找到的任何东西填平船只之间的区域。
From garbage to unwanted cargo to dead bodies, you name it, everything was thrown into that, and with this gradually began the process of filling in the mud flats. In this way, the shoreline itself began to advance. At this point, the harbor was a patchwork of freshly filled lots, ships, and buildings on stills. But then, in May of 1851, a massive fire broke out in downtown San Francisco. The wind fan the flames, and by the time the next day had dawned, more than 2,000 buildings were gone, the flames were so high that they could see the glow in Monterey 100 miles south. Some of the ships caught fire and sank, leaving their half-charred holes in the muddy water.
从垃圾、不需要的货物到尸体，应有尽有，所有东西都被扔进里面，泥滩填埋的过程也由此逐渐展开。通过这种方式，海岸线本身开始向前推进。此时，港口是由新填筑的地块、船只和高脚屋建筑拼凑而成的。然而，在1851年5月，旧金山市中心爆发了一场大火。风助火势，到了第二天黎明时分，2000多栋建筑消失了，火势之猛烈，远在100英里以南的蒙特雷都能看到火光。一些船只起火并沉没，在泥泞的水面上留下了半焦黑的船体。
By the time they managed to put the fire out, the waterfront was just a mushy mess of smoldering timber. And that mushy mess was too unstable to rebuild on, so they used some of the world's first steam-powered excavators to scrape sand off of nearby hills and dunes and dump it on top. By September of 1851, the old waterfront had been completely buried.
当人们终于扑灭大火时，海滨只剩下一片冒烟木材的糊状烂摊子。而这片糊状烂摊子太不稳定，无法在其上重建，于是他们动用了世界上最早的一些蒸汽挖掘机，从附近的山丘和沙丘上刮下沙子，倾倒在上面。到1851年9月，旧的海滨已经完全被埋葬了。
And with it, the nianctic, the Rome, and all of the other gold rush ships entombed in this manufactured ground. After the fire, San Francisco continued to expand, filling in more and more of the tidal zone in deeper and deeper water. And eventually the state stepped in. They built a seawall to cap the production of new land. They drew a line and said San Francisco you can go no further, and today we know that line, it's the Embarcadero. The walkway along the eastern edge of the San Francisco Wharf. But by that time a city had built up on top of all this sand and dirt and garbage.
随之一起被埋葬的，还有“尼亚加拉号”、“罗马号”以及所有其他被封印在人工填造土地底下的淘金船。大火过后，旧金山继续扩张，在更深的水域填海造地，填满了越来越多的潮汐区。最终政府介入了。他们修建了一道海堤来限制新土地的开发。他们画了一条线，对旧金山说：不能再往前了。今天我们都知道这条线，那就是恩巴卡德罗——旧金山码头东缘的步行道。但到那时，一座城市已经在这些沙子、泥土和垃圾堆上拔地而起。
And over the years San Francisco continued to develop, and today what had been the title zone is the heart of the city's financial district. Throughout history, the absence of ground has proven to be a surprisingly small obstacle for people who want to build stuff. Simpsisco isn't the only city that is built its own land. Large portions of Boston, Seattle, Hong Kong, and Marseille were built on top of Phil. It's not uncommon to see it in other cities, New York, Manhattan built out and filled. The area of the World Trade Center sits on with landfill.
多年来，旧金山不断发展，如今曾经的潮汐带已成为该市金融区的核心。纵观历史事实证明，对于想要搞建设的人来说，没有土地并不是一个多大的障碍。旧金山并不是唯一一个自己造地的城市。波士顿、西雅图、香港和马赛的大片土地都是建立在填海造地之上的。这在其他城市并不罕见，纽约曼哈顿的土地也是通过填海向外扩展的。世界贸易中心所在的区域就是用垃圾填海造出来的。
They actually found a ship when they were building the original World Trade Center towers. What is now mum-by-India used to be a seven island archipelago before the British colonial government turned it all into one contiguous strip of land. Tokyo has built 60,000 acres of new land over the last several centuries. The process of building new land along the waterfront is often referred to as land reclamation. Which is kind of ridiculous. Land reclamation is another one of those words that's made up and it masquerades what's really happening. You're creating land where it didn't exist before. Or even creating a whole country, like the Netherlands.
事实上，他们在建造最初的世界贸易中心双子塔时就发现了一艘船。如今的孟买（印度），在英国殖民统治者将其变成一个连贯的狭长地带之前，曾是一个由七个岛屿组成的群岛。在过去的几个世纪里，东京已经造了6万英亩的新土地。这种沿着海岸线建造新土地的过程通常被称为填海造陆。这其实挺荒谬的。填海造陆是另一个伪装了真实情况的虚构词汇。你明明是在原本不存在的地方创造土地，甚至是创造一个国家，比如荷兰。
There's a very extraordinary history of basically the Dutch making their own country. That's Stephen Graham, professor of cities and society at Newcastle University, and author of the book Vertical, the city from satellites to bunkers. I mean, most of Holland, most of the Netherlands, as it's currently constructed, is an engineering construction. It's a huge project of land reclamation and land manufacture. The Dutch developed incredible techniques to build land in places that were actually below sea level.
荷兰人自己造国的历史非常非凡。说话的是斯蒂芬·格雷姆，纽卡斯尔大学城市与社会学教授，著有《垂直：从卫星到掩体的城市》一书。我的意思是，荷兰的大部分地区，就像它现在的结构一样，是一项工程建设。这是一个巨大的填海造陆和人造土地项目。荷兰人开发了令人难以置信的技术，在实际低于海平面的地方建造土地。
And this has been going on since medieval times, where large dikes were constructed, large pumping systems were constructed to create a dry country underneath the sea. And the Dutch are proud of this history. There's a popular saying there, God created the world, but the Dutch created the Netherlands. Humans have been making their own ground for a long time, but the process has reached new heights in recent years.
这种情况从中世纪就开始了，当时人们修建了大堤，建造了大型抽水系统，在海平面以下创造出了一个干燥的国家。荷兰人为这段历史感到自豪。当地有一句流行语：上帝创造了世界，但荷兰人创造了荷兰。人类制造自己的土地已经有很长时间了，但在近年来，这个过程达到了新的高度。
The historic scale of land reclamation, and land manufacture, and the building up of land beneath cities is absolutely minuscule compared to the scale at which it's going on today. More and more cities are building waterfront property for airports, skyscrapers and housing. It's sheer urban economics because you create new supply in an area where there's amazing levels of demand and therefore it's very profitable. And new dredging technologies have enabled developers to build land faster and on a grander scale, often at the expense of the environment.
与今天的发展规模相比，历史上填海造陆、人造土地以及在城市地下堆砌土地的规模简直微不足道。越来越多的城市为了机场、摩天大楼和住宅而建造滨水地产。这纯粹是城市经济学，因为你在一个需求惊人的地区创造了新的供应，因此利润非常丰厚。新的疏浚技术使开发商能够以更快的速度、更大的规模建设土地，这往往是以牺牲环境为代价的。
I mean they use huge ships for example, which have what they call rainbow dredging systems. These ships suck up massive amounts of sand and gravel from the sea floor and shoot it through the air in a giant, arcing rainbow of muck onto the area where they're trying to build new land. This technology has been particularly useful for creating artificial islands. China is using these rainbow dredging ships to turn uninhabited coral atolls in the middle of the South China Sea into larger islands that could support human settlement. They're actually manufacturing land in the hopes of staking territorial claim to highly contested waters. And then, there's Dubai.
我的意思是，他们使用巨大的船只，例如拥有所谓“彩虹疏浚系统”的船只。这些船只从海底吸走大量的沙子和砾石，然后通过巨大的、呈拱形的泥浆彩虹将其喷射到他们试图建造新土地的区域上。这项技术对于建造人工岛屿特别有用。中国正利用这些彩虹挖泥船，将南海中间无人居住的环礁变成能够支持人类定居的更大岛屿。他们实际上是在制造土地，以期对极具争议的水域提出领土主张。然后，还有迪拜。
Dubai is a post to child for this process really. The wealthy desert Emirate has built a series of artificial islands for wealthy elites. Three of the new landforms are shaped like massive palm fronds. Another project called The World is a cluster of islands designed to look like a map of the world from above. But Dubai's reclamation project has stirred up so much sediment that they buried coral reefs, oyster beds, and sea grass fields in the Persian Gulf, and some of the islands that make up the world are already starting to erode back into the sea.
迪拜可以说是这个过程的典型代表。这个富裕的沙漠酋长国为富有的精英阶层建造了一系列人工岛屿。其中三个新地貌的形状像巨大的棕榈树叶。另一个名为“世界”的项目是一组岛屿，从上方看设计成世界地图的形状。但迪拜的填海项目激起了如此多的沉积物，以至于它们掩埋了波斯湾的珊瑚礁、牡蛎床和海草田，组成“世界”岛屿的一些岛屿已经开始侵蚀回海中。
Dubai is also running out of sand. At least the kind of sand you need to build things. Desert sand is too fine for construction, and Dubai has used up so much of the sand around its coast that they now have to import it from Australia. Globally, humans use over 40 billion tons of sand a year. The two largest uses of that sand are concrete production and land manufacturing projects. And it's created a global sand shortage that is forcing countries to go to extreme lengths in their efforts to build new ground. The most famous example here is Singapore. The wealthy island nation is one of the densest countries in the world.
迪拜的沙子也快用完了。至少是建造东西所需的这种沙子。沙漠沙太细，不适合建筑，迪拜已经用完了海岸周边的沙子，现在不得不从澳大利亚进口。在全球范围内，人类每年消耗超过400亿吨沙子。沙子的两大用途是混凝土生产和人造土地项目。这造成了全球沙子短缺，迫使各国在努力建造新土地时采取极端手段。最著名的例子就是新加坡。这个富裕的岛国是世界上人口最密集的国家之一。
And it's constantly looking to expand its territory. There's plans to make Singapore 20 or 30% bigger over the next 40 or 50 years through manufacturing new land. Without enough sand of its own, Singapore has had to look elsewhere. There's been a lot of evidence that the extended land manufacturing around Singapore, the basis for its growth as a tiny island city, is based on basically stealing sandy islands
它一直在寻求扩大领土。计划在未来40到50年内，通过制造新土地，将新加坡的面积扩大20%或30%。由于自己的沙子不够，新加坡不得不另寻他路。有大量证据表明，新加坡周围不断扩大的人造土地——也就是这个小岛城市增长的基础——基本上是从柬埔寨、印度尼西亚和缅甸等较贫穷国家“偷走”沙质岛屿，
from the poorer countries like Cambodia and Indonesia and Burma and then moving the material physically. Land itself is flowing from poorer countries to wealthier ones. Those countries have made sand exports illegal because of this sense that they are losing their own territory. Land manufacturing isn't just expanding territory outward, in some cases it's expanding upward. On the coast of Nigeria, developers are building a new luxury city called Eco-Atlantic, on top of manufactured ground. And the starting thing about Eco-Atlantic is it's about three or four meters higher than
然后将这些材料物理搬运过去的。土地本身正从较贫穷的国家流向较富裕的国家。由于意识到自己正在失去领土，这些国家已将沙子出口定为非法。造地不仅是在向外扩展领土，在某些情况下它还在向上扩展。在尼日利亚海岸，开发商正在用人造地基建造一个名为“Eko Atlantic”的新豪华城市。关于“Eko Atlantic”，最惊人的一点是它比拉各斯其余地区
the rest of Legos, and it's been designed to be more resilient to expected sea level rises than the rest of the city. Legos is a very poor low-line city that's extremely vulnerable to sea level rise. So there's a very disturbing, sort of almost apartheid geography emerging here, where elites are able to build their own escape routes from increasingly perilous conditions through going higher into manufactured land. In theory, building new land could be a part of the solution to sea level rise, but Stephen Graham says these new land projects are often built exclusively
高出大约三到四米，其设计比该市其他地区更能抵御预计的海平面上升。拉各斯是一个非常贫困的低洼城市，极其容易受到海平面上升的影响。因此，这里正在出现一种非常令人不安的、几乎是种族隔离式的地理现象，精英阶层能够通过进入更高的制造土地来建立自己的逃生路线，以应对日益危险的环境。理论上，建造新土地可能是解决海平面上升问题的一部分，但斯蒂芬·格雷姆表示，这些新的土地项目往往是完全为
for the rich. They are being built as private projects for those who can get in and can afford it. They're not being built as public projects very often to protect cities as a whole. Massive reclamation projects like eco-Atlantic are the most obvious examples of manufactured land. But even if you live far away from the coast, the ground beneath your feet may have been partially created by humans. People are continuously impacting the surface of the earth. We dig up rock from one place, grind it into cement, and build a sidewalk somewhere else. We blow up skyscrapers, dump the rubble somewhere, and build a hospital on top of it. And all of this human activity has actually created a new layer on the surface of the
富人建造的。它们是作为私人项目为那些能够进入并负担得起的人建造的。它们很少作为公共项目来保护整个城市。像“Eko Atlantic”这样的大型填海项目是人造土地最明显的例子。但即使你住在远离海岸的地方，你脚下的土地也可能是由人类部分创造的。人类不断地在改变地球表面。我们从一个地方挖出岩石，将其磨成水泥，然后在其他地方建造人行道。我们炸毁摩天大楼，把瓦砾倒在某个地方，并在其上建造医院。所有这些人类活动实际上在
Earth's crust. It's made up of old bricks, ground up cement, and rusting metal. Archaeologists and geologists have started calling this layer the Archaeosphere. The Archaeosphere isn't totally unnatural. It's filled with soil and roots and earthworms, sometimes grass grows on top of it. And that makes it hard for us to notice.
地壳表面创造了一个新的层。它由旧砖块、磨碎的水泥和生锈的金属组成。考古学家和地质学家开始将这一层称为“人类世地层”（Archaeosphere）。人类世地层并非完全不自然。它充满了土壤、根系和蚯蚓，有时上面还会长出草。这让我们很难注意到它。
Stephen Graham says that this idea, that human activity has actually created a geologic layer on the surface of the earth, is bringing archaeologists and geologists together. Traditionally, archaeologists study human artifacts within the ground, while geologists study the ground itself. But what if the ground itself was made by humans? Archaeologists are increasingly working with geologists and they see the ground as a gradual
斯蒂芬·格雷姆说，人类活动在地球表面创造了一个地质层的这一观点，正将考古学家和地质学家联系在一起。传统上，考古学家研究地下的出土文物，而地质学家研究地下本身。但是，如果地下本身就是由人类制造的呢？考古学家越来越多地与地质学家合作，他们将地面视为
accumulation of the leftovers, obviously it's rubbish, it's the bodies of the dead, it's the leftover materials, and it is increasingly part of the build environment, I think that's really important. Important for one, because we need to understand what the ground is made of, if we want to build safely on top of it. Manufactured ground can be unstable and more susceptible to earthquakes and landslides. For example, in China in Shenzhen,
废弃物的逐渐积累——很明显，它是垃圾，是死者的尸体，是剩余的材料，它越来越多地成为人造环境的一部分，我认为这真的很重要。重要的一点在于，如果我们想在它上面安全建造，我们需要了解地面是由什么组成的。人造地基可能不稳定，更容易发生地震和山体滑坡。例如，在中国深圳，
when the construction material that was heaped up on a hillside as part of the great expansion of that city, basically slumped down as a great big slide, and I think there was about 80 people killed in that as well. So we need to become much more aware that in creating our own geology we're also creating our own hazards. But the Archaeosphere is also a resource to be explored. There's been estimates that there's as much copper in that artificial ground as there is in all of the copper mines in the world. So in
作为该市大扩张的一部分，堆积在山坡上的建筑材料基本上像一场大滑坡一样滑落下来，我想大约有80人因此丧生。因此，我们需要更加意识到，在创造我们自己的地质的同时，我们也在制造我们自己的危险。但“人类世地层”也是一个可以开发的资源。据估计，人造地下所含的铜与世界上所有铜矿中的铜一样多。所以在
Scandinavia they're actually starting to mine the disused industrial ground of their own industrial cities. When you walk through a city coded in pavement and covered in buildings it's easy to assume that the ground beneath you is ancient and natural. There's a tendency always just to see the ground as something that's always been there and always will be there, but there's a huge amount of evidence that cities build their own ground, cities are agents for making their own geology. If you look at a brand new land reclamation project like Eco-Atlantic, it's obvious the
斯堪的纳维亚半岛，他们实际上开始开采本国工业城市的废弃工业用地。当你走过一座铺满路面、盖满建筑物的城市时，很容易认为你脚下的地面是古老而自然的。人们总有一种倾向，认为地面是某种一直都在并且永远都会在那里的东西，但有大量的证据表明，城市会建造自己的地面，城市是创造自身地质的动因。如果你看一个全新的填海项目，比如“Eko Atlantic”，很明显，
ground is manufactured. Right now it looks like a giant sandy construction site, but if all goes according to plan, pretty soon there will be parking lots and skyscrapers and apartment buildings. And right now it's hard to imagine that such a blatant example of artificial ground will one day become seen as just an ordinary part of the Nigerian landscape. But you probably could have said the same thing about San Francisco in 1850. 99% invisible was produced this week by Emmett Fitzgerald with Katie Mingle and Sheree
地面是人造的。现在它看起来像一个巨大的沙质建筑工地，但如果一切按计划进行，很快就会有停车场、摩天大楼和公寓楼。现在很难想象这样一个明显的人造地面例子有一天会被视为尼日利亚景观的普通部分。但对于1850年的旧金山，你大概也会这么说。“99%隐形”本周由埃米特·菲茨杰拉德制作，合作者包括凯蒂·明格尔、谢里·
Fusef, plus Sam Green's fans Lani Hall Kirk-Hulls dad Terran Mazza, Avery Trouffleman, and me Roman Mars. Special thanks this week to archaeologist Matt Edgeworth, who's writing about the Archesphere helped us a lot on this episode. Also Stephen Graham's new book Vertical is coming out this fall, you can find a link to it on our episode. Also, Stephen Graham's new book Vertical is coming out this fall. You can find a link to it on our website. We are a project of 91.7KALW San Francisco and produced on Radio Row in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. We have a lively community on Facebook. I'm on Twitter at Roman Mars like way way way too much.
富瑟夫，以及萨姆·格林斯潘、拉尼·霍尔、柯克·胡尔斯达德、特兰·马扎、埃弗里·特鲁夫曼和罗曼·马尔斯本人。本周我们要特别感谢考古学家马特·埃奇沃思，他关于人类世地层的文章对我们这期节目有很大帮助。此外，斯蒂芬·格雷姆的新书《垂直》将于今年秋天出版，你可以在我们的节目页面上找到它的链接。我们是旧金山91.7 KALW电台的一个项目，制作地点位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽的市中心“无线电街”。我们在Facebook上有一个活跃的社区。我在Twitter上的账号是@Roman Mars，发文实在太多了。
But if you want hundreds and hundreds of stories to make yourself sound really interesting at parties, I recommend you go immediately to 99pi.org. Radio to pee. From PRX. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
但如果你想要几百个故事来让自己在派对上显得非常有趣，我建议你立即访问99pi.org。Radio to pee。来自PRX。来自PRX。本集暂无评论。点击转录中的任意句子即可留下评论。